je me trouve dans un champ de miscanthus
aussi appelé le roseau de chine où
l'herbe à éléphant parce que sa
spécificité c'est que c'est une plante
très grande elle peut faire jusqu'à 3
mètres 50
d'habitude le miscanthus on utilise
comme biocarburant par exemple pour
chauffer sa maison
mais ici en eure-et-loir certains
éleveurs l'utilisent dans leur ferme
avant stéphane utilisé sa propre paille
comme litière pour ces dindes et ses
volailles il s'est vite rendu compte
qu'il perdait du temps voilà on en met
fois plus épais que ce à quoi donc
et pourquoi la paille c'est comme
d'habitude à la paille on va en mettre
beaucoup plus épais et là les animaux ça
reste sans est propre
longtemps économiquement pour stéphane
le prix du miscanthus est le même que
celui de la paille la paille
moi je la récolte il faut que je la
fasse ramassé que je la fasse broyer que
je la stocke que je létale
tout ça pour un résultat qui marche mais
voilà le miscanthus c'est bien mieux moi
je vais avec ma remorque la cherche le
chercher déjà broyer j'en prends quand
j'en ai besoin j'ai pas de récolter j'ai
pas le stocker jean-michel cultive du
miscanthus
la récolte se fait une fois par an et
c'est en ce moment son entrepôt sera
bientôt complètement vide son affaire
marche bien le miscanthus 7 à rhizome
donc on plante à rhizome et après mois
le réseau de pouce il faut trois ans
pour qu'ils y avoir une production
correct à l'hectare et puis après il n'y
a plus rien à faire juste le récolter
pas plus compliqué que ça le miscanthus
est aussi utilisé pour le jardinage et
pour faciliter la digestion des vaches
laitières
la plante est aussi écologique au bout
de deux ans le miscanthus se mélange à
la terre et se transforme en compost